We're continuing in our series, coming to the end of it, of Firm Foundation, where we're
looking at our church statement of faith together.
And last Sunday we looked at our statement on the church, and this Sunday we're continuing
with that.
So last Sunday we really focused on who the church is, or what the church is.
And this Sunday we're focusing on the practices of the church, so what the church
does.
And we've been looking at Acts chapter 2 verses 41 to 47, and so we're going to read that
again this morning.
Acts chapter 2 verses 41 to 47 says, So those who received his word were baptized, and they
were added that day about 3,000 souls.
And they devoted themselves to the apostles' teaching and the fellowship, to the breaking
of bread and the prayers.
And all came upon every soul, and many wonders and signs were being done through the apostles,
and all who believed were together and had all things in common.
And they were selling their possessions and belongings and distributing the proceeds
to all as any had need.
And day by day, attending the temple together and breaking bread in their homes, they received
their food with glad and generous hearts.
And God, in having favor with all the people, and the Lord added to their number day by
day those who were being saved.
This is the word of the Lord.
Years ago I read an interesting book called Tribe by Sebastian Younger.
And it's essentially a book, it's not a Christian book, he's not a believer, but it's a
book about the importance of living in community as opposed to living in isolation.
And in the book, Younger points to various studies that show that, particularly that
deep social bonds often form in high stakes environments.
So these social bonds, they form when you're in a kind of a threatening environment together,
and there people devote their energy to the good of the community rather than just
themselves.
So he gives battlefields as an example.
Wounds are a terrible place to be, but they often produce a depth of camaraderie that people
struggle to find in other places.
And he notes how difficult it can be to go from experiencing that kind of level of brotherhood
that shared experience, that shared purpose to then living in a modern world as a civilian
in a place where you're in a culture where isolating self-sufficiency is the name of the
game rather than living in an interdependent community.
Last week we saw that we longed for community because we were created for community.
We were designed for fellowship with God and fellowship with one another.
And we were made to experience that life together in the fellowship of the church.
You see the church is designed to be a place where we experience true community, joining
together with a shared purpose.
Of course we have to admit that the church doesn't always live up to that, and that
includes this one as well.
Nevertheless, it's what we're made for.
God is present and at work in us to bring about that kind of community.
In Acts chapter two where we're looking, we just to remind us God has poured out His spirit
upon His church, and the kind of community that emerges is remarkable.
And when you look at this community here, it gives us something to aim for together,
but more than that it shows us what happens when we are led by God's Spirit to become
the kind of people He has created us to be.
So yeah, we've got a wonderful aim here, but this is primarily saying, look, this is what
God is doing.
And if you're led by His Spirit and walking in step with His Spirit, this is the kind
of thing that happens in your midst as a community of believers, as a church.
Well any group that you step into, you might wonder, like, what do I have in common
with these people?
Maybe even look around the room today and think, what do I actually have in common
with the folks who are here?
And what I want to draw out is three things that we share in common together.
And the practices of the church hopefully will come through in that.
So we share, I'll go ahead and let you know, we share a common faith, a common life,
and a common witness.
Okay, so we share this common faith.
Acts chapter two begins with the church.
This made up of about 120 people, we're told, but by the end of it it now has over
3,000 people.
Now that is wonderful, but you can imagine all of the challenges that would come with
that.
I mean just imagine 3,000 people turning up this morning.
We wouldn't know what to do with them, like how many people could we have in here at
any given time.
So the church is facing all kinds of challenges, no doubt from day one.
The 120 people, remember, they had gotten to know one another pretty well.
These were people who had already been following Jesus together.
But they didn't know these other people very well.
How can you get to know 3,000 people?
And then the question then becomes, well, how can you know that they are part of the
church?
How can we be confident enough in these 3,000 people to say like, oh, the Lord has added
them to our number as the church?
Well, they can be confident, and here's why.
It's because those people walked through the same door that they walked through to
get into the church.
And by that, I don't mean the buildings, they don't have a building they're
walking into.
So if you can imagine the life of the church happening inside a house, if you enter this
house, you must come through the front door, all right?
So what is this front door that they've all passed through?
What's the, what's this common door that they've passed through into the common life of the
church?
Well, only God knows the hearts of those who initially walked through this door.
But as far as the church is concerned, we need to be ready to welcome anybody
who comes through this door.
Okay, what is the door?
The door is the gospel.
The gospel is the door.
Here we see that everyone who receives this gospel by faith and makes that public through
baptism is recognized here as being part of the church.
So let's see it together.
Verse 41, the gospel has just been preached and it says, so those who received the
word were baptized and they were added to that day, added that day about 3,000 souls.
These people in verse 41 are the they that you then have in the verses following.
So let's look at this together.
So you see the gospel is received.
They receive the word.
Peter has just preached a message that centers on the person and work of Jesus.
He preaches about Jesus' death.
He preaches about His resurrection and His reign over all things.
And the message is the same today.
Though we have rebelled against God's reign over our lives, the King has come into the
world and He has laid down His life on the cross so that rebels like us can be reconciled
to God.
So we've rebelled against God, but the King comes and instead of coming in wrath,
He comes and lays down His life in mercy so that we can be welcomed to Himself.
And today God still forgives anyone who will turn from their sin and put their trust in
Jesus as their Savior and King.
So those who have received Christ by faith are welcomed by God.
And in being welcomed to God, they are welcomed into this community called the church.
They've been welcomed by Him through Christ.
You know, there's a longstanding tradition in church buildings where you get these old
church buildings where the front door is painted red.
And that's a kind of a picture of the gospel because we all enter the church by way of
the cross through the death of Jesus for us.
So if we receive this message by faith, we're welcomed by God and brought into the
church.
We've also got this other thing that's told us about being recognized as being part
of the church.
So you have the gospel is received, but the gospel is also portrayed here.
It says those who received His Word were baptized.
So we're talking about the practices of the church and that includes baptism.
So those who received the Word and were baptized were recognized as having been added to
the church.
So what are we to make of this?
Well, let's be clear.
Baptism is not the gospel.
It's not.
So 1 Corinthians chapter 1 verse 17.
Hear these words from the apostle Paul and the distinction here.
He says, Christ did not send me to baptize but to preach the gospel.
So there's the gospel that's received and there's baptism and they're not the same
thing.
So do you hear the distinction?
We entered the church by the way of the cross.
Period.
But our entrance through that door is then made visible to others through baptism.
Okay, so baptism is not the gospel, but baptism is a picture of the gospel.
So those who trust in Christ are united to Him in His death and in His resurrection.
And so in baptism, going under the water is like being buried with Christ and being
raised up from the waters, like being risen with Him.
So baptism is portraying our union with Jesus and His death and His resurrection.
It's a sign and a symbol pointing to what Jesus has done for us.
So this happens inwardly.
It's an inward reality that's being united to Jesus.
And then others see that as we are willing to proclaim that in baptism outwardly.
This may help you.
It helps me as a kind of illustration.
When a man and a woman enter into the covenant of marriage, they are united together
as ones.
That's that kind of union.
That marriage ceremony is accompanied by a symbol, right?
The exchanging of rings.
I've got mine here.
And so the ring isn't the thing that brings about.
It doesn't cause their union with their spouse, but it is a public declaration of that union.
And if somebody says, well, I don't really want to identify with my husband or my wife,
you have to think something doesn't sound right there.
Similarly in baptism, we are identifying with Christ.
We're portraying our union with Him.
And we're doing so in a way that He commanded because Jesus commanded His disciples.
He said in Matthew 28, 19, go make disciples of all nations, baptizing them in the name
of the Father, Son, and Holy Spirit.
So if somebody is a disciple, they're following Jesus, they're identified with Him.
They make that known through baptism.
As they are entering the waters in that way.
And this is the practice of the early church.
As you read on in the book of Acts, you see baptisms happening when people respond in
faith to the message of the gospel.
They have that inward faith in Jesus, but this is expressed outwardly in baptism.
So the church stands ready to identify with anyone who is ready to identify with
Jesus in the way that He commanded.
And at Trinity, we stand ready to do the same.
We're ready to baptize anyone who has received Jesus as their Savior and King.
And we don't have formal membership yet.
Just so you know, that's the direction we are moving in, having formal membership
in the church.
And baptism will be part of that conversation in terms of being brought
into the membership of the church.
Now, recognize that raises questions and far more questions we can answer
just like right now.
And so I'm happy to talk with anybody about any questions they have in
relation to this.
But let me just address just some three quick ones here.
One is, well, what if I have a different conviction about the mode of baptism?
You know, I believe the gospel, but I hold to a different conviction.
And I can take you to scripture to show you why I hold to that conviction.
Let me just say, well, let's talk about that.
And if somebody holds a different conviction, but they hold to the
gospel and they've been baptized, we're willing to welcome them into
the life of the church, even if the mode of baptism might have been different.
But let's it's a conversation that we can certainly have.
Another question is, is baptism really necessary?
There's some who might not want to be baptized because it's a humbling
experience that they would rather just avoid.
But here's the thing, if Jesus is truly your Savior and King,
he calls you to follow him and to follow him in this way.
He's called us to identify with him in this way and know that baptism is such a
joyful occasion.
So yes, it is necessary because Jesus has told us to follow him in this way,
to identify with him in this way.
But another question may come up.
Is am I am I good enough for baptism?
May think, well, yeah, I believe that Jesus has died for me, but I look at
my life and especially when I look at my sinfulness and I think, well,
am I ready for baptism?
If that's you know that when you come to the waters of baptism,
you're not there to declare your goodness.
When we come there, we're proclaiming that we are sinners,
but Jesus died for sinners just like me.
You don't come because you're good enough.
You came because Jesus died for us.
And so we're proclaiming that Jesus welcomed sinners just like us.
It's not because we're good enough, but because of his gospel.
So we have this common faith that we share together and that is faith in Christ.
We make that known through baptism.
But that faith is also seen in our life that we share together.
So let's look at our common lives, our common faith.
We have this faith in Christ and now we've walked through the door into the
house, so to speak.
So what does life look like inside this house called the church?
A few brief things in passing.
One is remember, this is a life that is brought about by the spirits.
The practices that we're seeing isn't just like a list for us to kind of like
mark off.
It is evidence that the spirit of God is at work in his community,
the church, shaping us.
Another thing to just note in passing is this is a life that takes place
both publicly and house to house.
It's interesting, like the ongoing pattern we see in the New Testament is like
what we see in Acts chapter two.
So you've got them there, the gathering in the temple courtyards and public, but
then they're scattering and they're meeting together house to house as well.
And then the ongoing pattern we see is that the church then is gathering
particularly on the first day of the week, the day of the resurrection of
Jesus.
That's why all around the world today, people are gathering on the first day
of the week.
But then the church life isn't just seen in them gathering the first day of
the week, it's seen throughout the week in the places where they live.
They're following Jesus together in the context of everyday life.
And so here at our church, that's what we try to practice together by God's
grace.
We gather together on the Lord's day, but then we also want to follow Jesus
together right where we live.
And so that's why we have home groups in these different locations.
Another thing is it's a life of devotion.
So you see there's certain practices that they devoted themselves to.
Where devotion means they continually gave themselves to these things.
This is a language of, it's also a language of priority.
They prioritized these things together.
So there's lots of things that we do and even more things that we could be
doing as a church, but there are a few things that we ought to prioritize.
If everything else goes, these things remain.
And it's what has been traditionally referred to as the ordinary means of grace.
These are these primary ways that God shapes our lives together as His people.
What are they?
Let's walk through them.
One, the apostles teaching and they devoted themselves as verse 42 to the
apostles teaching.
So the apostles were teaching in the temple courts where kind of a larger
crowd could gather there that they were also teaching house to house as well.
You look at Acts 542, you see that ongoing pattern.
They're teaching publicly house to house.
So Jesus is nourishing and leading His church as His apostles are teaching what
they have been taught by Jesus and what they are being taught by His Spirit.
Now today we no longer have the apostles with us, but their teaching
is preserved for us in the New Testament.
And so we have the New Testament and the New Testament tells us how to interpret the
Old Testament as well.
But know this that Jesus is still feeding and leading His church by the
apostles teaching it's when we open the scriptures together.
So this is why we prioritize reading the scriptures, teaching the scriptures,
singing the scriptures, praying the scriptures, discussing the scriptures
together because this is how the Lord guides us.
I was listening to an interview this week on the radio.
It was on NPR and they had then had a word from their sponsors in between the
interview and this may sound harsh, but it's absolutely true.
A so-called church was the sponsor.
And I say so-called because here how they describe themselves.
Describe themselves as a non-credal community of faith or none.
So I actually looked it up.
A non-credal community of faith or none.
In other words, we don't have a particular belief that we hold to.
You don't even have to hold to anything to be part of that church.
And so what holds them together is a vague sense of togetherness,
kind of prioritizing community, but it's not the truth of God's word that is
holding them together.
And so if we're not held together by the truth of God's word, then what are we
following?
Like if we're following Jesus as our King, well, we want to hear what he has to
say to us.
So following him as our King means we listen to his word and seek to follow
it together by his grace.
And as we're looking to his word, we come to know him better.
And as we come to know him better, we are shaped into his likeness.
And all this comes through his word.
So we prioritize the ministry of his word.
The Apostles teaching.
Another thing, the fellowship.
The fellowship.
Well, this is a key word in the New Testament that describes the church.
And the word fellowship is a word that is pointing to both unity and partnership.
So we're united together in the fellowship.
We're also partnering together with the same purpose in view.
So later on, you know, it talks about the word together is actually used in verse
46, day by day, attending the temple together.
And so that's another word that's used.
It's like a fellowship word.
It talks about being in, it's a word that means being in one mind or one
accord living together with one purpose.
But notice the way their togetherness has lived out in practice.
I mean, you could look at just about anywhere here and see that first of all, to state the
obvious, they spent time together.
They hung out together.
They ate meals together.
You see this happening in the ministry of Jesus.
He's always spending time with other people, eating meals together with them specifically.
Now this is being seen in the life of the church.
And so we love doing that here.
We love hanging out before the service together, spending time together afterwards.
And just know that's not just something that we happen to like to do.
That is an integral part of church life.
Fellowship is part of our life together.
So we really want to prioritize that.
So we're a fellowship, not just in our formal gatherings, but when we gather together
informally as well, when we eat in one another's homes or out at a restaurant
or whatever.
We're the church wherever we go.
And our fellowship is an embodiment of this union we share in Jesus.
But notice as they spend time together, they are caring for one another.
As you read this passage, it is striking how deep the sense of mutual belonging ran.
I mean, it's almost, it's difficult for us to imagine in the West.
You know, when we were living in West Africa, I remember, so, okay, here's
the story.
I remember sitting at the end of our road and there was this like kind of coffee stand that
was there where local men would come and sit and drink coffee.
So I was sitting there having coffee with somebody.
And while we were talking, he was telling me just how, how needy he was financially and
how he was really poor and needed help.
And as he was talking about all of that as financial needs, and then I start hearing
this clinking metal sound coming down the road.
Clink, clink, clink, clink.
I'd heard it before and I didn't know what it was.
And he's saying, yeah, if you could really help me out, I'm really struggling financially.
And he snapped his fingers and put his hand out and started getting a manicure as he was
telling me about his, about his needs.
And so he's putting out his other hand for his manicure and he's putting out his feet
for his pedicure.
And, and at first of all, it was, it was humorous seeing that happen.
But then I realized what was actually going on.
It was reflective.
He didn't think anything about that because that was how community life happened there.
Because we're so self-sufficient in the West.
Like there, there was somebody in the area who had an iron and they were the local
person who did the ironing within the community.
So you went to get your ironing done there.
You had your local mechanic.
And if you were the local person with the clippers, guess what?
You had, you had a role within that community.
There was a kind of an interdependent community life that was there that we really don't
have a good picture of in the Western world in the same way.
But so it wasn't about luxury or extravagance.
Everybody contributed what they could and everybody benefited in different ways.
And this is what a spirit led church looks like.
It is an interdependent community where each member uses their, their gifts to care for one
another and to look after one another.
Notice how it happens in the passage.
We're told that they, they share all things in common.
They were even selling their possessions so that they could care for one another's
needs.
There wasn't a person among them who continued on with needs.
So instead of trusting in the illusion of self-reliance, they depended on and took care
of one another in community.
Now this isn't put here before us as a command telling us that we must all sell all of our
personal property.
In fact, if you just look here, you see that they were meeting in homes.
So somebody had to have the home that they were, they were meeting in here.
But what was, so what is it showing us here?
What is it telling us?
It's showing us the depth of care that should be seen in the life of the church, the depth
of care that is seen when the spirit is at work.
It's showing us the reality of this interdependent community called the church where we love
and care for one another in tangible ways where we are involved in both giving and
receiving within the life of that community.
Let me say like over the past like year, year and a half as we have gathered together,
I've seen this in so many ways across the life of this church.
I even thought about just opening up the floor now to just say like how have you seen it?
And I like throw up a hand if you want to share something specifically in the way that
you've seen this in the life of the church.
If you don't like I'll keep sharing but maybe, I tell you what, let's do that.
Think about this.
We'll go off script here.
What are particular ways that you have seen the church to be a caring community where
you've experienced that kind of care within the life of the church?
This isn't the time for all of us to have our own 20 minute sermon.
Maybe just give a couple of sentences of like this is a specific way I've seen the Lord's
work in the care of the church.
It would be good for us to name that and praise God for it.
So, anybody have anything they'd like to share?
Go for it, Mallory.
Thank you all a lot for the way that you all are kind of concerned.
Think so there.
To praise God, you're the last person who has heard too much of our life.
But tangibly, like you all have provided financial aid for us while we've been living
in a hospital and actually we've cleared evidence of the gospel through the body of
God.
Absolutely.
Yep.
And those with tools, using their tools at our house.
Allowing us to play with their power tools as well.
Anything else?
Absolutely.
I've been encouraged hearing about how home groups are going in terms of like sharing those
burdens together and giving a listening ear is a way of caring for a need and praying together
in that way.
And the more you think about it, I took some time to just think and pray over that yesterday
and just story after story came to my mind of ways that's been lived out in the life
of the church.
And so I just want to say praise God for what he's doing here already.
And let's pray that he continues to lead us in that way in community.
Let's move on.
We see that they devoted themselves also to the breaking of bread.
You know, there's some discussion as to whether this is just eating common meals together
or whether or not this is the Lord's Supper.
I think the fact that it talks about the breaking of bread is pointing to the Lord's
Supper.
But then as well, you don't have to separate that from a meal because it was the practice
in the early church to share meals together and as part of that meal to break bread in the
Lord's Supper.
And breaking of bread in the Lord's Supper is a lot like baptism.
So baptism is that a one time ordinance we are identifying with the gospel.
But then there's an ongoing practice, which is the Lord's Table, the breaking of bread
or communion, where the bread is reminding us of Jesus' body broken for us.
The wine is reminding us of his blood that was shed for us.
And so we're perpetually identifying with the Lord and with the gospel in that way as we
share in that communion together.
So the Lord's given us, He's made us a family.
He's given us a family table as well.
Let's move on.
We see, lastly, the prayers also.
As we're praying, we're saying we're dependent upon not ourselves, but the Lord's presence
among us.
He's the one who is bringing this community about and we're casting ourselves upon Him in
prayer.
And you know, you see some personal prayer in the Book of Acts, but overwhelmingly you
see the body of Christ praying together time and time again about all kinds of things.
So the Spirit of God wants to make us a people of prayer who consciously, depending
on the Lord together, calling out to Him because we share this common life not only
with one another, but with God.
Before we move on from this common life though, we're just going to spend just a fraction of
a moment on the common witness part in case you're wondering.
I want you to see how they did these things together.
Let's read verse, the end of verse 46, start of verse 47 together.
It says, they received their food with glad and generous hearts, praising God and having
favor with all the people.
So they weren't just following Jesus together.
They were following Jesus together gladly.
There was some serious sacrifice happening in the early church, but there was serious
joy as well.
Their lives are marked by giving, yes, but they're also marked by a spirit of generosity.
So all of these things that they are doing is flowing from a heart of worship and a heart
of love for the Lord and for one another.
Maybe the greatest miracle that we're reading about in these verses is not the fact that
they did these things, but the fact that they did these things from the heart.
And let me acknowledge that church life and church planting can be difficult.
And the fact is, like the closer we get, the more we can see one another's weaknesses,
all the comings and even the setting sins.
The work can be tiring and it can be easy to get cold and even cynical.
So let's pray together that the Lord would guard our hearts.
And we're going to get this wrong.
Let's pray that he would make us quick to say, I'm sorry to confess to one another.
Let's pray that the Lord would continually warm our hearts by the fire of his word as the
Spirit shows us more and more of his love in Jesus.
So that's our common life together.
It's from a common heart.
Lastly, we share a common witness.
You can imagine as the gospel is being proclaimed in the temple courts or in courtyards at
houses and like neighbors are looking on that people are are here in the gospel, wondering
what is going on.
And we're told that as that happened, more people were being saved coming to faith in
Christ being welcomed into the life of the church.
Verse 47, the Lord added to their number day by day, those who were being saved.
They were seeing new people come to know Jesus regularly, even daily.
I know this genuine conversion isn't something that we can manufacture.
This is something that the Lord was doing.
The Lord was adding to their number.
Only the Lord saves.
But this is something that we should long for and pray for.
But the thing is we can pray for this knowing that the Lord is able to answer that prayer.
There's nobody that he cannot save.
So let's keep praying that the Lord would add to the number of his church.
We would see people come to faith in Jesus.
You know, he uses us to point people to him by our words and by our lives.
And even our when we live as a gospel shaped community that is pointing to that truth
that saves.
You know, John 1335, we find the words of Jesus there by this, all people will
know that you are my disciples.
If you have love for one another.
Years ago we developed a dandelion problem in our backyard and they were getting everywhere.
And our kids were little at the time.
And the thing is like they pick up a dandelion and you don't just look at a dandelion when
you pick it up.
What do you do?
You want to blow it.
And that's wonderful and exciting.
But what happens where all the seeds go?
Where the seeds go?
More dandelions spring up.
This is what you see happening in the church.
Hang on, in Acts.
The Spirit of God is poured out.
The Spirit of God blows on his people.
And as they scatter, as they go out, Acts chapter 8, they scatter because of persecution.
But as they go, what do you see happening?
What you see happening in Acts chapter 2 is now happening in all the places where
they are going.
That common life that they shared is being lived out in these other places.
And new churches are springing up.
More people are coming to faith.
And the church multiplies not only throughout the book, but throughout the world and throughout
the centuries and to us today.
So it's come right here to where we are.
You know, as we prioritize this way of life that we read about here, who knows where
it could lead?
What if God's Spirit worked here in such a way that this church multiplied into planting
other churches in the future?
He can do it.
In fact, all these elements we've spoken of today, that can be done anywhere.
Think about all the things they didn't have, but they had the Spirit of God.
He was bringing about that community life together.
And we have the same Spirit.
We're part of the same church.
And the Lord can do that.
He can multiply this work through us.
So as we come to prayer now, and before we come to the Lord's table, just ask yourself
what your next step is with the Lord.
Maybe it's walking through that red door, walking into the life of the church by putting
your faith in Jesus.
Maybe it's participating more in the life of the church and that giving and receiving.
Maybe it's asking that the Lord would warm your heart once again, that you would not
just be doing those things, but from a heart of love for him.
So let's pause and quiet prayer.
And then I'll pray before we come to the Lord's table together.
So, Lord, we thank you for the gift of being part of your church, being made part of your
family, the temple where your presence dwells, living as citizens of your kingdom together.
And Lord, I pray that in our togetherness, Lord, that we would know the very love of
Christ at work in our midst.
Lord, that you would shape our life together in such a way that it would point clearly
to who Jesus is and what he has done for us.
Lord, we thank you for how you have added to the church, how you are growing us together
as a church.
And Lord, we pray that you would receive all the glory through the church.
And Lord, as we come to your table now, Lord, we thank you for what Jesus did for us
to bring us to yourself and make us part of this family.
But we thank you for his body broken for us and his blood shed for us on the cross.
And Lord, I pray that as we come to your table now that we would do so with glad and thankful
hearts.
In Jesus' name, amen.